[Music]
on this thursday night a timeline for
the covet 19 vaccine
new details on when canadians could get
the shot and
who will be first in line when a vaccine
is ready
canada will be ready plus ontario's dire
new prediction about where
its curve is headed constitutional
rights versus
pandemic restrictions are these measures
needed what is your right to personal
freedom in the middle of a public health
crisis
plus mercy for a mass murderer why the
sentence for the quebec
city moss gunman has been reduced and
an unparalleled ski season just
countless hours planning and prepping
and reimagining
everything that we do hope on the hills
for north america's biggest ski resort
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with more information about
vaccines for covid19 and canada's plan
to roll them out
at this point none has been approved but
several have shown so much promise in
clinical trials
health canada could greenlight them as
early as next month
for use as soon as the new year as
things stand now
we expect certain vaccines to become
available in early 2021
however it's important to note that the
initial supply of these vaccines
will be limited dr news says the first
batch would be 6 million doses
because two doses are required that
would be enough to vaccinate three
million canadians
three core groups would get them first
those at highest risk of contracting
covid19
those at high risk of transmitting it to
vulnerable people
and essential workers health canada has
given an emergency order to expedite the
approval process of the leading vaccine
candidates
and the government says it signed final
deals with five of the seven vaccine
manufacturers
it now has contracts with pfizer moderna
astrazeneca
sanofi and glaxosmithkline medicago
novovax and johnson johnson enough to
supply 194 million doses to canadians
canada will have to rely on those
companies to honor
the contracts and ship the vaccine and
the closer we get
to this becoming reality the more the
pressure mounts
that's where the political fighting
begins david aiken has our top story
tonight
my information had been given to us on
vaccine delivery and distribution
a day of confusion our understanding was
that this had been finalized by the
federal government
now it appears maybe it is not and
clarifications
we expect to get six million doses of uh
at least two of the three uh vaccines uh
in
quarter one of 2021. so uh that's part
one
of the answer uh the minister is
incorrect but more than one province has
complained about confusion and
uncertainty from ottawa
when it comes to vaccine delivery so on
thursday
doctors and federal bureaucrats tried to
set the record straight
our goal is to enable as many canadians
as possible to be immunized as quickly
as possible
against covet 19. ottawa is already
putting in place the freezers the
syringes and other material
that will be needed to deliver this mass
immunization program
the military has been called in to help
when a vaccine is ready
canada will be ready and health canada
said it is on a similar timeline to the
u.s
when it comes to be able to issue
approvals u.s
regulators will decide december 10th if
the pfizer vaccine will get the green
light and
since canada is getting the same data as
the us at the same time
canada anticipates no lag time in the
approvals process
still vaccinations on this side of the
border
are unlikely to start in december
instead federal officials are confident
that at least three million canadians
will be vaccinated
starting in january and ending in april
i think the most immediate hope is to
protect those people on the front lines
the healthcare workers give them some
relief and also the very most
vulnerable seniors from infections
still it will be up to the provinces to
make the final decision
on who is first in line for a vaccine
and the country's premier still have
lots of questions about this
vaccine rollout plan and they'll get a
chance to put their questions to the
prime minister this evening
when they all get together for their
22nd teleconference
since this pandemic began donna
okay david aiken in ottawa thanks a
vaccine can't come
soon enough cases of covid19 are rising
in virtually every region of the country
these are the active cases in canada
based on yesterday's numbers
quebec ontario and alberta have more
than ten thousand active cases
alberta has the most closing in on
fourteen thousand
that's more than ontario which has over
three times the population
yet alberta has done the least to impose
restrictions to stop the spread of the
virus
in calgary now intensive care units are
operating at over capacity
the statistics of course aren't just
numbers they are people
one of them is 40 year old ricky lamb
from edmonton
his family says he was diagnosed with
covid19 on a thursday
and he died a few days later to their
knowledge he did not have
any underlying health conditions heather
urex west now on the human toll in
alberta as the virus keeps spreading
always full of life always out
exercising and energized and
dancing on the dance floor and sweating
it up over the course of three days
edmonton's ricky lamb shared his
symptoms on instagram
at emergency because my breathing has
suddenly gotten worse
reads the first post later x-ray is
apparently showing signs of covid
he would later share he tested positive
and three days later
in his final post breathing has become
very difficult
every few breaths i go into a coughing
fit it's so brutal
it doesn't allow me a chance to recover
at just 40 years old lamb died the next
day
we're now in a situation where this has
a life of its own
intensive care units across the province
are now at or near capacity
and those on the front lines fear the
number of deaths from covet 19
will begin to sharply rise certainly in
my view
the measures that have been put in place
are very weak
this former alberta chief medical health
officer also believes that recently
announced restrictions
don't go far enough that failure to be
able to count on contact tracing
means that we should be pivoting to the
second strategy
which is the kind of lockdown we saw and
that was effective
in the spring and so that's what i would
be pushing for
for many decisions i present a range of
policy options to government officials
outlining what i believe is the
recommended approach the final decisions
are made
by cabinet dr dina hinshaw has not said
publicly what her recommendations to
government were
but according to her predecessor if
there was conflict with government there
is little chief medical health officers
can actually do it's a core competency
of public health to be able
to speak truth to power but there is
virtually no protection for the people
who do that
so you can be dismissed without cause
almost anywhere in this country on the
whim of the government
a difficult situation that ultimately
the virus will judge
reflected soon in the number of new
infections and patients requiring
hospital care
heather urex west global news calgary
late today dr dina hinshaw addressed the
release of some audio recordings made in
secret
of government meetings she was involved
in the cbc says it obtained 20
recordings of daily planning meetings
that it says reveals serious
disagreements
between the chief medical officer and
politicians
this is a personal betrayal and a
betrayal of the trust that our
hard-working team has placed in each
other
i know that there are many views about
how we should proceed
however we are becoming divided when we
most
need to engage in respectful dialogue
in ontario new modeling projects the
curve is flattening in some areas but it
varies widely and it's difficult to tell
if it's part of a turnaround
today the province reported 48 new
outbreaks
cases are down in long-term care homes
but the number of deaths is still rising
so are hospitalizations increasing 63
percent
over the past four weeks occupancy in
icus is also on the rise
ontario's top doctor says right now no
new restrictions are needed because the
ones in place
are having an impact there is some
positive signs we're seeing
a good direction but it's still
precarious
and we have to watch that and we're not
as bad as we were
but we're not out of the woods yet in
this matter
a toronto restaurant owner has become
the poster boy of defiance against
covid19 restrictions
he was taken away in handcuffs today
after refusing to obey public health
orders and close his place
to in-person dining most canadians have
accepted the restrictions are in place
to limit the spread of a deadly virus
but there's a vocal minority who believe
their personal right to freedom trumps
everything else
and as eric sorenson reports some
political leaders have given them tacit
support
when a public health lockdown is imposed
and restaurants ordered shut
civil liberties are restricted but is it
unconstitutional
one restaurant owner in toronto has been
arrested after reopening this week and
testing the limits of government power
he and others protested restrictions
ordered by toronto's medical officer of
health the city's mayor
on u.s cable news said there must be
respect for the law in this country
it is founded on the fact that if you
don't like a law you can go to court or
you
can seek office and try and change the
law by getting yourself elected
but you don't just kind of thumb your
nose at the system a similar response
elsewhere
after an anti-mass gathering defied
health protocols in steinbeck manitoba
the province's conservative premier
supported police issuing fines
this is not about our opposition to
protest
this is about our opposition to those
who disrespect public health orders
another large anti-mask march took place
in calgary on the weekend from the
premiere of that province a different
tone around health restrictions jason
kenney says he's concerned decisions on
the pandemic are being driven by
ideology
i am disturbed that in all of the covet
debate
there seems to be almost no discussion
about the impact on fundamental rights
and freedoms
one specialist in health law was taken
aback by kenny's stance
i agree that we shouldn't let ideology
win the day
what we want to win the day is good
evidence
good science and a balanced approach to
tackling
this pandemic the canadian civil
liberties association is concerned by
possible government overreach
and the uneven impact of restrictions on
some canadians
there are at least very real questions
about whether the restrictions that have
been put in place
are are necessary and can be justified
but while striking a balance on personal
freedoms experts say governments have a
duty to protect the health of canadians
in extreme circumstances
uh governments have the right to act for
the good of the people and it makes the
the balancing act very very difficult
but
are these are these measures needed
absolutely eric sorensen global news
toronto there is no doubt some
businesses
are suffering buckling under the weight
of debt and it's women and racialized
canadians who are disproportionately
affected many work or worked in
restaurants the canadian chamber of
commerce warns bankruptcy
could be just weeks away for some
businesses and as abigail beeman
explains it's urging the federal
government to change some of the rules
around the emergency rent subsidy
program
we have around 200 staff we have a
lineup out the door the place is packed
at 750 peopleish
now we only have about eight staff i
describe it as in
walking on eggshells we just don't know
what's going to happen even by the end
of tonight
because the laws change so much hours
cut
tips slashed thousands of restaurant
employees live with the constant worry
of another layoff
another shutdown i wake up as a
president of the company i try to look
at our people in the eye and say you
know is there something we can do today
to make sure that
we can keep your jobs mo jessa says the
federal government's wage subsidy was
critical for earl's restaurants
but it's not enough global news obtained
this letter from the canadian chamber of
commerce to deputy prime minister
christian freeland
calling for changes to another program
the new canada emergency
rent subsidy we want to make sure that
everybody is treated equally
business owners can claim up to 65
percent of 300 thousand dollars in
expenses
the issue is for owners of more than one
place
the rules mean they need to split that
amount across them all
in our case that's less than 10 percent
of our rent
cost across our business paul bogner's
company has seven
brands and 58 restaurants monthly rent
tops two million dollars
the government doesn't think that the
jobs the five thousand jobs that exist
in
in our company are as important or
important at all
as the franchise or the single unit
operator
across the street who they're providing
full funding for i do think that there
should be a cap
of some sort again to ensure that the
program is helping as many
types of businesses as it can and not
forgetting
about the standalone businesses if our
guests are not earning as much as they
used to then they won't be as generous
to us
and then that is like a domino effect
and then if we go to starbucks we just
don't have
for example or tim hortons we just don't
have then
you know enough change to tip our
baristas a spokesperson for freeland
pointed to the additional
25 percent rent subsidy top up
for businesses forced to close due to
local rules there's no
overall cap on that and a government
source tells global news the retooling
of the rent program was done with the
restaurant industry in mind
but they're certainly open to more
feedback abigail beeman global news
ottawa some relief could be coming for
restaurants in ontario where in-person
dining is banned the province wants to
slash fees that food delivery apps like
ubereats and doordash
charge in ontario those commissions can
reach up to 30 percent
the proposed law would cap delivery fees
at 15 percent and total charges it would
max out at
20 percent the aim is also to ensure
companies don't restrict their delivery
zones or cut out certain restaurants
something similar was done in new york
city
a change to the sentence of the quebec
mosque gunman coming up why a court has
ruled the original sentence
was cruel and unusual
the man who killed six people in an
attack on a mosque in quebec city has
had his sentence reduced
alexander bissonnette was originally
sentenced to life with no chance of
parole for 40 years
today quebec's highest court cut that
back to 25 years without chance of
parole
mike armstrong explains the decision and
why it likely
will be appealed it was a sentence that
from the minute it was handed down
didn't make either side happy in fact it
was appealed by both
alexander bissonette's defense team and
the crown
now bissonnette pleaded guilty to six
murders and six counts of attempted
murder traditionally that would mean six
life sentences
with no chance of parole for 25 years
but the sentencing rules
changed with legislation in 2011 and the
judge could have handed down consecutive
sentences
that's what the crown wanted no chance
of parole for 150 years
the defense wanted it concurrent capped
at just 25 years
quebec superior court justice francois
went in a completely different direction
he handed down the 25 and tacked on
another 15.
he decided that the legislation was
unconstitutional but he kind of rewrote
it in a way that he felt it would be
constitutional
well in a decision handed down thursday
the quebec court of appeal
says that was a mistake the judge didn't
have the power to add a new option
but it also went further the appeals
court is declaring the 2011 changes to
the criminal code that made consecutive
sentences possible
invalid i'm glad that the court
concluded that the legislation
could give rise to sentences that are
cruel and unusual
and it's now unconstitutional
a spokesperson for the quebec city
mosque where the attack took place
says the community is hurt by the
reduced sentence
he says they'll respect the justice
system's decision but
questions whether actual justice has
been done
while the debate is far from over
observers say it's a certainty the
question of consecutive sentences
will head to the supreme court but it is
in a way for someone like bissenet
basically academic he can ask for parole
after serving 25 years
but considering the heinous nature of
the crime
he's very unlikely to get it mike
armstrong global news
montreal vancouver's city council has
voted unanimously to ask the federal
government to
decriminalize possession of small
amounts of illicit drugs the city will
ask the federal government for an
exemption from the controlled drugs and
substances act it's part of a plan
to develop a health-focused approach to
substance use and end the stigma against
drug users
2020 is on track to be the worst year
for overdoses
last month the bc coroner reported 162
overdose deaths about five per day
if approved vancouver would be the first
jurisdiction in canada to decriminalize
small amounts of street drugs
for personal possession still ahead the
final offensive fears grow for civilians
caught up
in an ethiopian conflict
the situation in ethiopia is getting
worse tonight the country's prime
minister has ordered the army to move in
on the capital
of the tigray region in a statement abi
ahmed says the military offensive has
reached its final stage
he urges citizens to stay home and away
from potential targets
more than 40 000 ethiopians have fled to
nearby sudan
since the fighting began earlier this
month
[Music]
and this is the kind of honor usually
given to heads of state tens of
thousands of argentinians lined up for
hours to pay their respects to diego
maradona the soccer star dazzled the
world and led argentina to win the world
cup in 1986.
he died of a heart attack yesterday at
the age of 60.
we're back in a moment
germany's chancellor is calling for
european ski resorts to remain closed
until at least
early january italy and france have
shown support for the idea but austria
has voiced concern
and mountains in switzerland which is
not part of the eu are already open
ski resorts in europe were among the
first covid19
hotspots here in canada whistler black
home in bc
opened for business today it's got the
snow and some pandemic protocols in
place but
what's missing are the tourists and
their money global's paul johnson is in
whistler paul donna you know this was
never certain and of course things could
change very quickly
but north america's biggest ski resort
and canada's most well-known
open for business this morning and their
intention is
to try to stay open for the entire
season
what's making this possible is the way
they've organized sales
and how they're managing numbers on the
mountains
their formula is this they know what
their capacity is for getting people up
and down on the lifts and gondolas
while observing social distancing that
tells them
how many people they can accommodate and
those spots
then have to be reserved online and in
advance
so there are no walk-up ticket sales
right now the executives here say it's a
work in progress
but they're asking for people to be
patient the team has done an amazing job
and just countless hours planning and
prepping and reimagining
everything that we do so that we could
operate and
our goal for the year is to get open and
to stay open for the whole year and uh
today is the first step
first day back so stoked we're open
you know it's obviously a bit different
than we all hope
but the snow is better than last year
of course the other big question here is
what's going to be the story
for all of the restaurants bars hotels
and service businesses
that rely on big visitor numbers in
order to survive
well that's most certainly going to
depend on the status
of the various travel restrictions
across canada
and internationally and whether at least
some of those
might be lifted at some point this
season but bottom line
the biggest economic engines of this
place are the two mountains themselves
and with the lifts running at least
there's some hope
donna all right paul johnson and wessler
thanks
and that is global national for this
thursday i'm donna friesen
we leave you tonight with an update on
rocky he's the little owl rescued from
the christmas tree at rockefeller center
in new york city while
rocky has had his fill of the big apple
and after 10 days recovering at a
wildlife center
there he goes he's back in the forest
where he belongs
thanks for watching take care of
yourselves bye-bye